GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE SO LONG
AS DONALD TRUMP IS OUT OF
OFFICE.
HERE WITH REACTION, DONALD TRUMP
WITH THE INTEL COMMITTEE AND
LET'S START
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
GREGG JARRETT POINTED IT OUT ON
AIR LAST NIGHT, AND THAT IS THE
FEDERAL RECORDS ACT ACTUALLY
GIVES AUTHORITY TO A FORMER
PRESIDENT TO HAVE CUSTODY AND
CONTROL OF PRESIDENTIAL PAPERS.
NOW WHEN YOU ACCOMPANY THAT WITH
THE TIMELINE THAT WE KNOW OF
THAT IS FEBRUARY, AND THE
ARCHIVES AND RECORDS
ADMINISTRATION WAS PRAISING THE
TRUMP TEAM FOR THAT COOPERATION
AND IN JUNE EVERYTHING THEY
WANTED TO SEE.
AND WOULD YOU MIND PAD LOCKING
THIS ROOM?
AND THEY DIDN'T, WHEN HE PUT ALL
OF THAT TOGETHER AND THE
PRESIDENT'S ABILITY TO
DECLASSIFY, WHERE DID THEY GET
THE PRESIDENT ON ANY LEGAL ISSUE
HERE?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THEY DID
GET HIM ON ANY LEGAL ISSUE HERE
AND THAT WAS THE HEADLINE OF
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
YESTERDAY WHICH WAS DEAD ON
ACCURATE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LEGAL BASIS.
THIS IS NOT THE GASTRIC'S.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND WHAT WE SAW WITH WHAT WE
JUST DISCUSSED IS THAT THEY ARE
HIDING THE DOJ MEMOS AND LIKE TO
SEE THEM AND REJECT THEM, AND
WHEN PUSH MAKES SHOVE, IT IS NOT
A FAVOR, IT IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO SEE THAT THE DOCUMENTS
ARE DECLASSIFIED AND HE HAS THAT
RIGHT.
AND WHAT IS THE BASIS?
HE WAS COOPERATING.
>> Sean: WE HAVE BEEN GOING
FOR THE RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX
AND THREE LONG YEARS OF
UNAPPEALING EVERY LAYER OF EVERY
ONION WE HAVE HERE, WHAT IS
FASCINATING IS THE SAME FBI
OFFICE THAT WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
RUSSIA COLLUSION FALSEHOOD THAT
THEY PERPETRATED ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE SAME EXACT PEOPLE.
NOW WHY WOULD WE BELIEVE THEM
NOW, WHY WOULD WE TRUST THEM NOW
AND WHY WEREN'T ANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WELL, LOOK, WHICH IN IT, AND
HIM AND HIS TEAM HAVE BEEN
REPLACED BY A NEW CABAL.
AND LOOKING AT THE LEGAL TEAM
HOLDING UP.
IF IT IS INDEED TRUE, AND THEY
WENT ON TO THE NEW YORK SPM Y
CASES AND WENT ON TO JANUARY 6,
AND WENT ON TO THE RAID AT
MAR-A-LAGO, THESE PEOPLE ARE NO
BETTER THAN PETER STRZOK AND
PAIGE.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS COMES
THROUGH, BECAUSE THE EMPHASIS ON
MUELLER SHOULD BE THIS.
HIM AND HIS TEAM SHOULD BE UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
I CALLED FOR IT AT THE TIME AND
STILL CALLED FOR IT TODAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF DURHAM WILL EVER
GET TO THEM, BUT PERHAPS MAYBE
SOME OF THE FBI AGENTS ARE
INVOLVED IN THE LATEST RAID.
>> Sean: GOOD TO SEE YOU AND